Now that we have our landscape created, we're going to take a look at how we can use a few
of the tools Unreal Engine 5 provides to sculpt the landscape.
Now the tools that we're going to be using are going to include the Sculpt, Erosion,
Hydro, and Noise tool, but there are other tools that we can use which I encourage you
to mess around with outside of this tutorial.
Now to use the tools, you simply click on which tool you want and then the left mouse
button will apply the brush and if you hold down shift while pressing the left mouse button,
you will do the opposite.
So for example, if I'm on Sculpt that I press the left mouse button, I will raise the terrain
up.
If I hold down shift and press the left mouse button, I will push that terrain back down
or make it go negative.
Each one of the tools, there's also going to have some tool settings, but there are some
tool settings and brush settings that are common between any tool that you have selected
that involves a brush.
This is both the tool strength which controls the intensity that the applying brush has
on the landscape.
So the closer this number is set to one, the stronger, the more intense that effect will
be.
One pro tip with the tool strength is that less is often more with this, so using numbers
like 0.1 or 0.2 are going to have a much better result and allow you to have more control.
Brush size allows us to control the size of our brush and we can also use the shortcut
key left bracket and right bracket to increase or decrease the brush size.
Brush falloff allows us to control the falloff or how dome like our brush is going to look
as the falloff increases to 1, we're going to get a smoother looking brush and then as
we decrease that number back to 0, we're going to get a much sharper brush especially at
the sides.
This last option we see here, use clay brush, we'll demonstrate this in just a little bit,
but this is unique to the Sculpt tool and we'll turn the Sculpt tool into this additive
brush which allows us to make some really interesting features that we can further refine later
on.
So let's go ahead and pop over to the editor and start using the noise tool to break up
our landscape and our goal is to get something that looks kind of like this where we have
some highs and some lows and let's go over to the editor now.
So inside of the Unreal editor, we want to make sure that we are in landscape mode so
if you're not, we come up to selection and go to landscape and then we're going to select
here the noise tool.
We're going to make sure our tool strength is set to 0.2, that our noise mode is set
to both and I'm going to increase my brush size a little bit, probably something like
that and what we're going to do now is I'm just going to start to paint here by holding
again the left mouse button and you can see here what it's doing is it is increasing and
decreasing the height of my landscape.
So spent the next few minutes increasing and decreasing the size of your landscape to give
you some nice areas to work with.
You can also mess around with the various options inside of the tool to kind of really
get a feel for how things are working and again we're trying to get something that looks
like this.
Now once you have gotten that, the next tool that we're going to look at is going to be
the sculpt tool and specifically with the sculpt tool we're going to enable this use
a clay brush option and what this is going to do is it's going to make it really easy
for us to kind of make the beginning of mountains.
So let's take a look at how we do that now.
So in the editor I'm going to click over to sculpt and I'm going to make sure that my
use clay brush is enabled which it is here and then I'm going to decrease my brush size
and something like that and we can see here as I start to paint in one area I get these
really nice looking kind of round mounts.
Now if I was to disable the clay brush here you can see it's going to bring it up more
brings up the slopes a little bit more and in some instances that's great but I'll
oftentimes I find that when I'm trying to begin an area trying to make some mountains
that look kind of cool or some plateaus or something like that that using the clay brush
in this manner works really well.
So now what I want everybody to do is spend a little time going through their area and
figuring out how they're going to make various brushes work for their project.
Remember you can also use the bracket keys to bring the brush down in size so left bracket
goes down and then right bracket goes up to give you some variation in your project.
Then once that is complete we're going to use the smooth tool to smooth out areas of
our landscape and you might often click on the tool over here and you might think that
well let's just do something like this and just smooth everything at once and while that
might give you results it is really going to destroy everything.
What you actually want to do here is we want to make sure that things like I'm going to
also set this down to like 0.1 that things like this are you know not too crazy for us
here because that's going to result in some weird rendering from the triangles but it's
also just not going to work for when the player tries to run over it or view it it's going
to look like an error.
So again just kind of smoothing out kind of areas that we have so we get some good looking
topology but we're also kind of keeping the highs and the lows.
Remember I set that tool strength down to 0.1 because I want to just barely get some
of this stuff smoothed out so I still have some really cool looking terrain to work with
when we go to our next step which is going to be applying erosion and stuff like that.
So spend the next few minutes pause the video and go ahead and smooth things out so that
you get a little bit of a smoother result here and when you come back we're going to
take a look at using erosion.
Now the erosion tools are used in a similar manner as the smooth tool.
We don't want to apply erosion to everything we want to start somewhere and apply erosion
locally and what I mean by that again is we don't want to come in here with our erosion
so I'll come here to this erosion and bring this you know we don't want to apply this
this might work but it's not going to give us the best results.
What we want to do here is start at the top of something and I make my brush really small
and remember erosion starts at the top and brings stuff down so when we're doing erosion
we always want to start at the top and bring things down that's going to give us the best
looking results.
So again what I want everybody to do now is using the various tools that we just talked
about the sculpt the erosion the smooth and we can even use the hydro again with the hydro
we want to do from the top down to the bottom so you can see it's going to give us a similar
result to erosion but I want everybody to spend some time now really working on getting
some great looking just terrain using these various tools and when you have something
done like this go ahead and move on to the next part where we'll talk about creating
material that we can use to help paint our landscape giving it the look of grass, rocks
and dirt.